people are full of antibodies a lot of
antibodies these proteins are a vital
part of the immune system but just how
the body makes such a variety of them
mystified scientists a decade the human
immune system has to fight off an
endless variety of bacteria viruses and
parasites and for each invader
it needs a specific antibody luckily it
could generate billions of them each
slightly different ready for any disease
but these antibodies made from two light
chains into heavy chains a protein and
Finian's of different proteins should
need billions of genes to make them
humans have around 20,000 genes the
solution to this problem was a Nobel
prize-winning discovery antibodies are
made by b-cells like every other cell
b-cells start off with the same 20,000
genes but they also have an enzyme
called rag rag is a DNA shuffler it
targets the genes that make the
antibodies binding site there are three
kinds of gene segments here called V D
and J for the heavy chain of the
antibody humans usually have around 130
different V segments 27 B segments and
6j segments the rag enzyme binds to one
of the j segments at random and then to
one of the D segment chopping off the
spare DNA between them other enzymes
then join the end together the same
thing happens with a randomly segment so
you end up with a G composed of one V
one D and one J join together this
provides over 20,000 possible vbj
combinations for the heavy chain the
light chain can have another 400
possible gene combinations combining
heavy and light chain gives
approximately 8 million different
possible antibodies each with a
different binding site and that's not
all
during the joining extra DNA is added or
removed at the junction
of the segments which takes our antibody
diversity from the millions into the
billion this is how our immune system
can respond to diseases it's never even
seen before
in fact there's so much diversity that
one of our antibodies could potentially
bind to almost any target in the whole
universe
[Music]